hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that just ended from round
five of this year's fed Grand Swiss it
is ala fuja versus H moken Neeman and
it's it's quite a brutal game a lot of
lines to cover let's dive straight into
it alza has the wide pieces and he opens
with Knight to F3 and aside from winning
the tournament ala would uh well very
much like to do to qualify for the
candidates tournament he also has to
look out for his rating as if he doesn't
qualify uh via winning the tournament he
might qualify for the candidates via
being the highest rated is currently he
and Hikaru are in a race for for that
spot uh Pawn to D5 countering the ready
with D5 we have Pawn to G3 the king's
Indian attack Knight to F6 and now
Bishop to G2 E6 we have castles uh and
Bishop to E7 D3 we have castles and now
uh there are a lot of games that reach
this position Knight B to D2 is pretty
much the only move that um people play
here uh while some others are possible
like C3 Pawn to C4 uh however here we
have Rook to E1 and there are only a
handful of games with this um exact move
order uh so okay Hans deals with this by
playing Knight to C6 which looks very
odd you might expect something like Pawn
to C5 but no he puts the knight in front
of his Pawn uh much unlike what filor
thought us all those years ago we have
Pawn to D4 by Ala the game again
position has been reached before Knight
B to D2 is a no
Andre yeno played against Vladimir fedos
in the Russian Championship 2021 and
fedos W that game but here we have Pawn
to D4 and it is now already as of move
seven that we have a completely new game
so Pawn to A5 hun starts grabbing more
space on the queen side he wants to go a
for A3 and now Knight to C3 ala does the
same puts the knight in front of his own
Pawn now this is something you will see
uh pretty much uh you know on opposite
sides of of the rating like this is
something your uncle plays and also
something that super Grand Masters would
do uh Knight to E4 and now Knight to B5
H getting the Knight out of the way so
now you can push the pawn but also in
some Lins maybe preparing Bishop to F4
to go after the C7 Pawn so okay A4 Hans
continues his expansion on the queen
side and now uh Bishop to F4 putting
pressure on C7 so of course you have to
counter that Bishop to D6 and now Knight
to E5 by Ala Knight captures we have D
captures now attacking the bishop and
Bishop to E7 and only Now Pawn to C4 so
putting pressure on hans's Center but
hanses Bishop to D7 now you cannot
capture or your knight on B5 will hang
so ala brings it back Knight to A3 and
now Bishop to C5 putting pressure on the
F2 pawn and there are a couple of ways
you could defend this but just Rook to
F1 not complicating and what I mean by
not complicating is that if you play E3
uh then all sorts of nasty IDE IDE has
become possible let's say Bishop B4
attack the rook and once you move the
Rook then you can play Bishop captures
on A3 uh you eliminated this Pawn here
uh this piece here and threaten to
double uh the pawns on the queen side
but there's a nice in between move see
captures on D5 and look at this now e
captures Queen captures now still
attacking the Knight and the bishop so
you will have to give something back but
now Bishop G4 attacking The Rook Queen
captures on d8 Rook captures and now
Rook to C2 now we're going to play
Knight captures on F2 and after Bishop
to G5 attacking this Rook Now Pawn to F6
and after e captures G captures Bishop
H6 attacks The Rook Knight to H3 with
check Bishop captures Bishop captures
and only now will you play B captures on
A3 The Rook will move uh so the bishop
doesn't capture it also you defend the
C7 pawn and you get this position where
the material is equal it's the Bishops
of opposite colors and white also has a
doubled a pawn so it's you know equally
or or maybe black is slightly better due
to the doubled a pawn uh but uh yeah
that's why you don't complicate with E3
solid is just brings The Rook back Rook
to F1 Pawn to F6 now Hans wants to break
um Al is a strong Pawn on E5 and now e
captures an F6 uh Knight captures on F2
Hans wants to play for more than a draw
here and he goes for uh the attack
basically giving up two pieces for The
Rook but he will also have the open f
file to attack ala's King so okay Rook C
capes on F2 Bishop captures on F2 and
now King captures on F2 we have Queen
captures on F6 uh and King to G1 of
course you don't want to see E5 or G5
well the king is on the same file as the
rook and the queen so King to G1 and now
Queen captures on B2 putting pressure on
the Knight here and queen to C1 you
could also play something like Knight to
C2 then we have A3 and the position
continues this way but ala wants to keep
his uh pieces more more active so he
plays Queen to C1 he gives up a pawn uh
to to start activating his pieces so
Queen captures on E2 and now C captures
on
D5 uh we have e captures on D5 and now
ala has some 17 minutes on the clock and
Hunt has only 11 minutes on the clock
and this position is just uh really
really wild to calculate you have to
take so many uh moves into consideration
like do you get the Rook into the game
go after the B7 Pawn do you capture on
D5 do you Capt on C7 so those are all
all valid ideas and the bishop captures
on D5 comes with check so of course why
not start with that King to h8 and now
Queen to C3 very nicely done going after
the black king also defending the Knight
here Bishop to E5 is coming the problem
is if you want to be too greedy with
Queen captures and C7 Queen D3 just wins
in the spot it attacks this bishop it
attacks the Knight here also threatens
Queen to D4 check to win The Rook on A1
and here basically you just resign so
instead Queen to C3 now Bishop D5 might
also be coming so hun brings The Rook
into the Game Stops that and now Bishop
captures on B7 and well it seems like
ala figured all of this out here hunts
threw in this C6 move which kind of
keeps the light Square Bishop out of the
game and this light Square Bishop is a
crucial defender of the light squares
surrounding the black king So how do you
how do you deal with this well
objectively best is to bring the Knight
into the game via the C2 Square and now
if something like Bishop to H3 you just
play Bishop captures on C6 and no
worries the Checkmate is defended
however in the game uh as ala was also a
very long time he played Knight to C4
and he allowed hunt a very very tricky
idea uh which hunt didn't go for uh but
he also did go for maybe an even
trickier idea that he did not go through
fully and what I mean by this is that
Bishop D6 is super annoying here
attacking the Knight and offering The
Rook on E8 and if if you go for this
let's say Bishop captures on C4 Bishop
captures on E8 Rook captures on E8 and
now Queen to D4 sorry Queen to D4 uh
then A3 comes and okay you play this
position with uh excellent chances for
black the pawn on A3 is just an absolute
monster however uh in the game after
Knight to C4 hunt played Rook to E4 he
went after the Knight this way and now
ala has to play well he could try a lot
of things like Bishop to A6 to defend
the Knight or there's even a really fun
variation with Knight to D2 going after
the Rook sort of forcing H to give up
the exchange here and after G captures
Rook F6 to go after the white king now
the idea behind Knight to D2 is Knight
to F1 so you can block check with Knight
to G3 now Rook captures on F4 Bishop
captures on C6 and now Queen to F2 with
check King H1 and now Queen to D4 and
this is uh basically a very very uh
Quick Draw Queen captures Rook captures
Bishop captures you're going to play
Rook captures and now Rook captures on
F1 comes with check King G2 Rook to f8
to stop Checkmate black is up a pawn but
this is a draw however after Rook to E4
Queen to D2 was played by Ala and this
sort of loses the game for him but only
if hunts can figure out why now I could
ask you to pause the video right away to
figure it out but I'm not going to do it
just yet I'm going to show you what
happened uh next here uh Queen captures
on C4 was played uh but are there any
other moves that you might consider here
uh well uh I Will Show You Queen
captures on C4 was played Queen captur
on D7 was played taking the piece back
and now only now I will ask you to pause
the video even though you kind of could
do it on the previous move but it would
just be too hard feel free to pause the
video and win the game for hunts while I
give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who able
to do it congratulations on spotting
this incredible idea that even Hans
missed and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Rook F to
E8 the idea is of course to Rook to E1
check which will result in Checkmate
very quickly uh or if you stop that by
any means let's say Bishop to D2 then
okay white doesn't get checkmated but
now uh this just wins the free Bishop on
on B7 and that's pretty much it Queen
moves you're going to pick up the bishop
you're up too much material the white
king is completely open and you will
Checkmate him very quickly so that was
in the position however he missed it he
played Rook to E2 and now ala can bounce
back into the game with a move like Rook
to C1 it's a basically a free developing
move H but he played Bishop captures and
C6 and now he again allows Hans to go in
for the kill queen to C5 with check King
H1 and now Queen to F2 going after Queen
captures an H2 Checkmate so Queen to H3
only way to stop Checkmate and now Rook
to E1 with check we have Rook captur on
E1 Queen captures on E1 and now King to
G2 we have Queen to E2 with check King
to G1 and now uh hans's position is uh
much much better probably even winning
uh to a degree but uh he has to play uh
the only move that wins the game but he
was below one minute on the clock now
I'm sure you guys already figured out
what the move is but Hans played Queen
to D1 with check uh the way to win this
is to play A3 uh not to go after the
pawn because you really don't want to
give up the D4 Square to the light
Square Bishop then white will simply
have too much counterplay uh this is the
way to do it and now you will have time
to reorganize your pieces it's not easy
because you're constantly uh going to be
uh in the threat of Checkmate however I
will show you because it's a lot of fun
Queen to D7 and now after you capture
the pawn now of course white goes after
the rook and now you have to figure out
how to defend your own King while also
make progress in the game and and you do
it by playing Queen A1 check King F2
Queen to D4 with check King E2 and now
you double up on the dile and you are
now ready to start pushing um uh your
Pawn uh of course if if Queen captures
then Queen to D1 with check will be too
deadly so Bishop to E8 now blocking the
rook and threatening Queen to f8
Checkmate but now you play Queen to D1
check King F2 Queen to C2 with check
King to F3 and now Rook to D3 with check
the white king escapes via the G4 square
but not for long Queen to C8 with check
King to H4 and now you force a queen
trade with Queen to d8 White will have
to trade captures captures and once the
bishop moves you will put the Rook
behind the pass Pawn push the pawn win
the light Square Bishop for the pawn and
then you will have a rook and two pawns
against a rook Bish against a bishop and
two pawns and where you can win this
well it's uh it's a question but you
will of course have a have a chance
however Hans played the queen to D1 with
check and now ala brings his Queen into
the game Queen captures King captures
and now Pawn to G5 this is the end game
that he chooses to go into so he wins
the dark Square Bishop not the light
Square Bishop Bishop captures on A4 and
now G captures on F4 we have King to G2
and now King to G7 uh Bishop to B5 by it
is a king to H6 we have Pawn to A4 now
the pawn is nicely defended here F
captures on G3 and this F captures on G3
is is now basically a draw offer as
there there is no way to continue the
game H captures uh Rook to F5 and it was
now un 40 death time control has been
reached so the players are no longer in
time trouble and they did um play a few
more moves of course hunts will try
something even though objectively it's a
draw Rook to C5 he attacked the bishop
got his King into the game a little bit
uh but there is no way to actually make
progress here so they danced around a
little bit but after uh all is a show
that he's not planning on losing this of
course they agreed to a draw on move 53
uh so yeah really wild stuff very nicely
played by both of them Hans definitely
got his chance with the black pieces but
in this crucial moment U uh okay the the
one where he was below one minute on the
clock not really counting that where you
have to play A3 because you just don't
consider such a move uh with with the
Bishops and the queen going after your
own King uh but here this would have
been very clean just Rook F to E8 and
it's it's resigns time there there's no
way to get out of this so yeah uh Great
Escape by Ala and great game by Hans all
in all a very very nice game uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh a fair result a draw I would like to
wish a very happy birthday to De no
vodopia and I would like to thank John
gear Law Office Mario Milano the brers
on Spotify and Stephen mccan for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens uh in the FED Grand Swiss uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day